Let's go, uh, where do we want to go next?
Let's go to the five, seven one area code.
Who's calling today from five, seven one.
Hi David. Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
All right. Hi, this is so Christian from Northern
Virginia.
Hey, how are you?
I'm doing well. How are you? Good. So I wanted
to talk to you about it, so I want to get
us out just for a forthright, uh, I'm an Elizabeth
Warren supporter. I started off supporting
her then when she was not doing well in the
polls, I decided to switch to Bernie. But
when she started gaining momentum, I was like,
yeah, I really connect with the way she's
messaging and her policies and her approach
to her campaign. And so I'm solely with her.
And so the thing I wanted to address is, um,
first of all, I really appreciate your very
fair and objective critiques, analysis of
and comparisons with her and other candidates.
But one thing I wanted to address is people
say that one critique of Warren that I hear
over and over again is that she's going to
take a big money or corporate money in the
general election, which she admitted if she
gets a nomination, which she admitted to.
I agree about that. But, um, they say Bernie
won't. And you said that too. And I haven't
seen any source that says that he will not
take big money in the, in the general election
because he did take big money as a Senate
candidate in 2018 just as warranted. In fact,
he and Warren raise the same amount in large
dollar donations in 2018 and they transferred
the same amount to their presidential campaigns.
Correct. So I'm not sure why we're saying
I just, I just want to get it out that, um,
we should be very fair in, in comparing those
two. Do you, have you seen anything that contradicts
what I'm saying or do you agree?
Well, listen, I, so I don't have a source
in front of me. So my understanding was that
previously Bernie Sanders had said he will
not take the money at any level of the campaign.
Now it sounds like what you're saying is you've
not seen that said definitively. And so therefore
it would not be a logical to presume that
he might in the general election, but he's
simply not talking about it. Is that more
or less what you're suggesting?
Yeah, that's what I'm suggesting and what
I'm seeing is if he were, if he did not take
that pledge, if he did the same thing, Warren
did, like leave it open in the general. Yeah,
I would be okay with that because general
elections or ad are extremely expensive and
Trump is going in with a massive fundraising
advantage. But what do you think about that?
I've said before, I've said before that I
think it is great for candidates to, to, to
decide not to take money of whatever sources.
They don't want to take it at any point. I
do think that in the general, it's not crazy
to make the argument that if you unilaterally
disarmed by saying, I'm not going to take
the money that you are setting yourself up
to lose, and then we're all worse off because
then Trump gets reelected. So I don't have
a super strong position one way or the other.
I can see both sides of it, but I'm not someone
who's going around smearing Warren because
she plans to do it in the general. I think
that you greatly diminish your chances of
winning if you don't.
I I completely understand. And thank you very
much for that. And yeah. All right. That's
it. That's what I wanted to know.
All right. Thank you. I appreciate the phone
call. Great to hear from you.